my name is Jeremy sicne 21 years old
live in Toronto I went to Evans
three-day workshop and from there I just
started my own YouTube channel I'm also
an investor Q&A time how can I help
what do you got I'm just pumping out
content yeah a lot now on YouTube but
the views aren't coming in which is
normal of course okay and I hear a lot
of people talking about running like
stuff like Facebook ads okay or
promoting videos through ads and stuff
like is that a practical should I be
spending money at this early in the game
to just rank it no yeah the only reason
to run ads is if you need the vanity
metrics for something mm-hmm it
basically makes you look bigger than you
are
and if that helps you in some respect to
help you close a deal or something then
then you can but paid ads very rarely
convert to subscribers you'll spend a
lot to get subscribers mm-hmm so you'll
get lots of views but you won't get any
engagement and you won't get any new
subs from it if you have money that
you're spending I would spend it on how
do I get better with my content and if
you're doing thought leadership stuff
like is you talking to this camera
talking ahead stuff like what I do then
it's then it's you like you've got a
fancy camera recording here too it's got
this Sony fancy camera microphone that's
enough that's more than what I had you
got a nice you got a nicer tripod than
me a nicer camera than me the variable
is gonna be you honking are you a good
at you on camera how good are your ideas
how could it you would swing me and the
people like it if people like your
content it's never been easier to share
yeah people love this they can share it
mm-hmm if they think it's garbage
they won't yeah yeah true and if it's
just okay then they won't either like
yeah okay I learned something awesome
but I'm not gonna show my friend that
yeah so it's it's getting the content
good enough and that's that sucks and
it's the best mm-hmm it sucks because
like man
it means you suck right yeah you gotta
get better but the good part is is all
under your control like you're not
limited by how much you can spend them
on an ad on Facebook or on YouTube so
it's good it's just it's an advantage
for you because you work hard mm-hmm and
so if you everyday keep keep practicing
practicing practicing practicing getting
better at the craft so that some people
recognize it and what you'll find is you
may have a video - that blows up for
whatever reason but it's more you just
start getting more people so on my
youtube channel I don't know how far
back like when you when you first found
me and what I was doing but a couple
years ago so there's been some people
who've been like oh geez like right from
not quite the beginning but close so
we're still sticking around and they've
seen the transformation and for me
because my content I wasn't very good on
camera I don't that much of what I said
or opinions have changed that much
you've just gotten better at explaining
them in better energy and yeah more
emotional commitment I had people in the
early days and they loved what I made
mm-hmm the better I get the mark and
widen the funnel yeah so the people who
are listening to you right now and say
wow that's really helpful there's a tiny
little percentage mm-hmm I mean your
goal is to just increase that by half a
percent yeah every month yeah
I'm slowly hitting more people right I'm
slowly getting better yeah it's not that
it actually sucks it just can only hit a
couple people because it's not you're
not good enough yet I deserve to be
where I'm at but I don't deserve to have
10 million subscribers I don't deserve
the sell out arenas cuz I hit X percent
of people which is better than I did
before but it but I won't hit as many
people as a Tony Robbins well mm-hmm
because he's better at the craft than I
am and that's awesome I understand the
frustration because it's always looking
for ways to like how do I ever get
better and I feel the same thing and I'm
always hacking and these things that you
can do to hack as well if you look at on
YouTube especially if you have any
opinions on on current trends that's
happening so I'm the weakest at this
because I don't follow the news
pay attention to trends and what's
happening I know I'm ignorant in most
things I know a lot about like four
things and nothing about everything else
I get that yeah as a strength and a
weakness but whatever happened today
Elon Musk said whatever not your buddy I
wanna give your point of view if you
want to be a thought leader that's what
you have to do is give a perspective
that people didn't think about before
so shifts our thinking yeah also if you
want to know what I think and what other
successful entrepreneurs think about
building confidence check out my new 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 250 4 days for free I will
send you a 30-second five-minute video
in the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you loved you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it the
most important word ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon if you want to
learn seven of the fastest ways to grow
a YouTube channel check the link right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so today I'm gonna share with you
with the help of my friends the seven
different ways to quickly grow your
YouTube channel